A local functional medicine doctor, I know, just told me today about two products from
biotics research, receptor detox. It does what it sounds like and hormone balance and
protect, supposed to have the same effect, some low dose, they'll treat them. Have you
heard of these products? And if so, will you think about them? Okay, so yes, I've heard
about these near two new products by biotics. We actually carry both these products. Here
they are. This one is the hormone balance, I think, one or the other. And quite honestly,
when they came up with them, they sent me three bottles of them. Quite honestly, I'm not
really impressed. So, biotics has some really good products. They have really good
glandulars. I really like their glandular products. We've carried biotics for decades. If
you're looking for them on our store, understand they just change their policy, we can't have
any other products visible on our store. So people have to call in to buy their products
right now, which that's their policy. So it is. These are why I'm not super impressed with
this product is, okay, so it's got calcium degluterate, which could be good for hormone balance
that's good. That's cilantro, which is a which is a help with heavy metal toxicity,
dandelion, which is a help with liver balance and helping with detox pathways. Parsley, which
is myter, myter player with detoxing things, chorella, which again, cilantro and chorella
would in my book would be mild detoxers and milk this for liver issues. It's really not.
This is really, that's why I was wondering why they're there. This is billed as a receptor
detox. This is really not pulling estrogens off of reset. If you want to really name something
receptor detox, if you want to say you're you're pulling estrogens off of receptors, then
you have to talk about fermented soy. So that's the only thing that will dislodge estrogens
from estrogen beta receptor. So that's the only product that's out there now, is that
hyalinide by one. That's the only product that is out there that does that. So I was disappointed
in their name, to this product and thinking this is what it is. And then this one is another
is a good product for forebode balance. Still just got a balance of supplements that most
everybody's already taking these. And then it's got panna broccoli, which, I mean, it's
good to have broccoli sheet extract. I mean, that's what so far as I am is. Grape sheet extract,
most people have that and other things boron and did say can be good for the brain and
the blood brain barrier, stingy dental, which can be good. It's a flavonoid that can decrease
inflammation and milk this for the liver. To me, this is just not a very specific or complete
product for forebode balance whatsoever. So I was quite honestly, I think they were all
with the products. I was just so disappointed how they're selling it. It's just to me, I was
super disappointed. I just thought, you get it.